الفرحه مستمره عرس من عالم اخر زواج
بمراسم ملكيه وثقافه اردنيه خالصه عكست
حياه الاردنيين وتفاصيلها الدقيقه بالفعل
عادل هذا ما كان عليه زفاف ولي العهد
الاردنيه الامير حسين من عقيلته الاميره
رجوى ال سيف هذا الزفاف ابهر العالم وحضره
المئات من الشخصيات السياسيه والاعتباريه
من دول عديده شاركت الاردن افراحها الزفاف
الملكي شهد العديد من الفعاليات الفنيه
والفقرات الاحتفاليه الشعبيه والتي ميزت
الفلكلور
والتراث الاردني بشكل كبير اللحظات
المميزه كانت كثيره السعاده الفرح على
وجوه الحاضرين كانت السمل ابرز لعل اجمل
الاشياء التي كانت وشهدناها في يوم زف
اف في التاريخي حيث اجتمع الاردنيون جميعا
كما راينا تحت شعار نفرح بالحسين
[موسيقى]